okay so if you know anything about cs go
you know that back in 2015 after a few
years of being really really good valve
rendered the m4a4's ugly stepbrother the
a1s
trash unusable what scholars
philosophers and fortnite kitties would
refer to as dog water and then about two
weeks ago with the release of operation
riptide valve made one tiny little
change to the a1s that has since sent it
whiffing back into the inventory of
every counter-striker worth their salt
the question is are we entering a meta
of sorts should you switch
and most importantly
why
[Music]
now before we all start collectively
unscrewing our suppressors just for
shits and gigs i'ma be a shill real
quick and ask that you like the video
subscribe to the channel
and turn on notifications okay so for
those of you who don't know and judging
by the number of you heckling me in
retakes for equipping the silencer there
are quite a few of you
the m4a1s has indeed been made the ct's
go to
chad weapon choice
again i won't get into the history of
the m4 since
well i don't have time but once upon a
time back in the days of 1.6 and source
the
saw tons of use this is because the cts
had one m4 that they could silence or
unsilence as they saw fit it was only
when cs go came out that valve gave cts
the choice between two m4s the
unsuppressed a4 available at launch and
the optionally suppressed a1s which due
to popular demand was actually added
near the end of 2013 in the arms deal
update i know i know i said i wouldn't
get into the history of all of this
suffice it to say for like two years the
a1s was
genuinely goated
like you were trolling if you didn't use
it to this day warlow put it best what
does the m4a1 bring to the table that
the m4a4 doesn't have well
most everything so in an effort to level
out the playing field a little bit valve
nerfed the a1s in 2015 by increasing its
base bullet spread and lowering its
armor penetration and rate of fire the
result however
was
well i mean it was pretty it was pretty
close to catastrophic no one ever bought
it again the end okay that's obviously
not true but the rate of fire reduction
really did make it this sort of niche
highly situational selection that you
could only really justify if you planned
on holding really long angles or
spamming through smokes otherwise the a4
was just always the safer option valve
were aware of this of course and did on
occasion try to bolster the a1s's
popularity with things like ammo and
price changes but it was almost always
to no avail for literally half a decade
the a4 stood as the superior most
submissive and altogether breedable m4
is that too far
m4a4 by far quite simply because it's
better it has a higher dps and like the
only situations where the silenced one
is better is uh
if you're
like spraying through smokes etc because
tracers the biggest reason for this of
course is that even now you can only
equip one m4 at a time which means you
pretty much had to take the a4 since it
was better in the vast majority of
circumstances if cts could have access
to either the a1s for sure would have
seen more action but valve didn't opt to
go that route instead they decided to
buff the a1s in a way that
[Music]
actually [ __ ] mattered as of
operation riptide the m4a1s now delivers
increased damage to everything that is
in the head so chest arms abdomen pelvis
and legs what does that mean
it means
that this boy slaps no more 98 in four
no sir this sumbitch now four shots from
anywhere on the map thanks to last
year's price reduction it's also cheaper
than the a4 and has better recoil and
it's suppressed which is not
insignificant though everyone knows that
if you are a real e-gamer you gotta be
like my boy jericho
and let it bark once in a while oh you
took the silencer off the let it bark
baby
let's go baby my game sense is through
the roof right now um i'm blind so i
gotta rely on my game sense
[Music]
i am actually nuts
who am i
so should you switch m4s
well with the buy menu as is where you
have to pick one over the other
it seems like you should as machine
observed on hlt confirmed the damage
buff combined with years of micro
microbuffs have made it so that the a1s
is better in virtually every way it's
come gradually right to the point where
now all of the changes compounded with
the bullet damage change could lead to
an overpowered or a much stronger rifle
like it was they added an extra 30
bullets to the mag right or something
like that
on top of the extra clip and 25 bullets
25 75 25 now 25.75 plus new bullet
damages on top of that and a cheaper
price
slowly drip fed us a better gun in fact
as a liege expressed pretty explicitly
on twitter there is actually a decent
chance that the a1s could be a little
too strong
we're already seeing the vast majority
of pros switch to the silencer with only
a few select positions sticking with the
a4 the only advantage of the m4a4 is the
faster rate of fire and the fact that it
doesn't stick around corners the m4a1s
is suppressed it's cheaper it does more
damage it has better recoil i think
we're gonna see a shift in the meta from
m4a4 to m4a1s so are we entering an a1s
meta of sorts
i mean look it's obviously a little
early to say but judging by the last
like two weeks of pro play it certainly
seems like it the gun just feels
incredibly easy to use especially at
range where you can just eviscerate
people with body shots and honestly it's
a welcome change the ct economy has been
floundering for quite some time and even
though it's only the difference of two
hundred dollars giving the cts a more
lethal more accessible full buy option
that goes toe to toe with aks at long
distances
could honestly be game changing this in
combination with the droppable utility
change
could really shake things up come the
major it'll be interesting to see
whether certain maps become more or less
ct sided and why of course the best part
about the silencer being back in style
is the skins being back in style the a1s
has long been heralded as boasting the
best cosmetics in the whole of cs go and
it was always reckoned to be such a
waste since well the gun sucked the
price of certain high value a1s skins
has already stonked though not as much
as i would have thought also now that
the a1s is god tier again i must make
one single simple request of the cs go
devs
please i would never be so presumptuous
as to suggest a balancing or gameplay
change
but please
for the love of gaben add a separate
[ __ ] keybind for taking off the
[ __ ] silencer take to twitter support
this noble cause and together we can rid
counter-strike of accidental a1s and
usps oriented misclicks forever anyway
that's
about all i got for you today if you've
been off cs a while and you haven't yet
given the silencer a whirl
you really should it is clean af
i can't wait to see how much use it gets
in the major
which reminds me we're getting a major
guys a major
meet back here after simple wins
meet back here after simple wins
i'm the master dude i get [ __ ] by these
guys all the time the trick danny the
trick danny is you just have to do what
i just did to you you have to just take
them so off guard that they legitimately
just like they're stunned it's just cc
you know it's a form of cc it's like an
ari fear you know what i mean like they
just don't know what to do like they
just they get yeah dimitri shockwave did
in fact find them all with a submissive
with a submissive
[Music]